you know I have an obsession basically
with power and money is power and you
don't have a platform without that and
then it calls us when he wants to commit
suicide you gotta get you're gonna get
worn out I'll tell you that thank
you sir but they just placed item
the wall with the exponent can I have
all of my high income folks and on the
other side
I think the opposite side judges me to
decide that I stand on
there is there is judgement society
seems to think that it's based on mental
conditions alcohol abuse or drug abuse
that we are in the streets where most
the times it's not and I do feel judged
by the other side because I feel like
most people have an innate massive
inadequacy and insecurity within
themselves well as they start as human
beings so jealousy is a natural tendency
mass majority of people have and that's
the root of why they're not successful
to begin with
I don't think jealousy is natural law I
think we were all born exactly the same
and to say it's inherited I think is a
bunch of BS it's all learned behavior
and I'm telling you if we took these
people on that side and they were
trained to have different beliefs and
judgments they'd be wealthy as hell
every human being is incredible from the
start I don't know I guess I don't
really spend that much time around
people who are on the other side so I
don't feel like I don't know what they
actually think about me there's enough
open-minded people that do really well
that's very kind and so I don't feel
like the other side just
I sort of started on the other aisle
I grew up sort of low-income
neighborhoods broken homes but for me
that was something that kind of gave me
that drive to want to achieve and to me
I would say that that's been something
that's been very helpful to me so I
would like to see what it's like to be
on the other side for once I was saying
yeah I would like to learn from them I
would help my mother but it depends on
what they're doing if it's illegal or if
it's something against my conscience
that would step back I don't know how
they got their money yeah you know once
you attain financial security whatever
that means to you as individuals you
realize it's all for nothing it says it
in the Bible every live a live in Hebrew
it means it's all for nothing
the reality of why we do all we do is
because we're looking to feel fulfilled
and that's why I have no problem going
back because fulfillment doesn't come
from money I was scared
a lot of times if you speak how much
money you make that's a great way to get
sued and let people know you have
something to get it
so sometimes it's better off to not let
people know what you got
I caught the realization that wait a
minute I'm supposed to work so hard in
life to get a job to married a woman who
wouldn't marry me if I didn't have that
job so that's why I look at a lot of my
forms as friends readings from his
friends
they boast this and that but I asked him
a question if you didn't have that money
in that job would she still be with you
she wouldn't so so I'm never afraid to
tell you how much a hundred percent yeah
if someone really loved you is always
enough if someone does I know never be
enough and so I'm gonna just tell people
how much I make my whole life and that
also weed out all the people I want no
part of most of my friends were true
friends are the best time we ever have
or like simple conversation like this do
you feel like money is power
yeah and I've seen it and what we in the
illegal ways I've seen it too it does it
works it is manifested power is there a
higher power is there a higher spiritual
level certainly but in the level that we
operate in yeah I mean if you want to
get something done you need some sort of
financial backing you know generally
speaking money is energy it's that's all
it is so inform it is power its power to
be used in a good way a power to be used
in a bad way money will only amplify who
you are as a person to a larger extent
if you're a douche bag you're gonna be a
bigger douche bag you're a sweetheart of
a person giving you're gonna become more
forgiving human being that's all that
money is gonna do might be a good idea
to go talk to Gandhi
maybe you want to talk to mother teresa
the thing about power is you speak
something and it occurs
do you speak something and does it
happen and if you've gotten money or if
you don't have money it's basically the
bottom line is is what is my purpose of
life and am i boom having it happen all
you got to do is look at somebody's life
you can look at people's auras all of us
have a certain worry it's real obvious
sure and you know whether you're making
a difference not you can't fool anybody
[Music]
once you attain financial security and I
said this earlier
it's just excess for me I'm a 31 I
probably reached financial security when
I was like 21 10 years ago self-made no
daddy no mommy nobody and I was very
fortunate to recognize what success
means the responsibility of success and
also what I want out of life
money doesn't motivate me anymore I
didn't come here today to show off that
I have money I came here because
hopefully I learned something that I
didn't know yesterday and that I also
could hope maybe influence someone that
didn't know something the same being
wealthy is having no wants I think I've
got just about everything I need I'm
pretending to have a lot more don't need
it well yeah for me it'll never be
enough you know I have an obsession
basically with power and money is power
and you don't have a platform without
that so if you want to provide a
positive message you need that power and
without money you can't really have but
that's not gonna solve your 1/8 problem
of wanting more no it's not and I and I
accept that at the door it's like you
can say it about drugs 1 another line
you can set about womaniser you want
another girl you can say it about
anything that you have in an obsession
for abundance of right right so that's
the not the problem but that's the the
why the money part is just the that's
some price
I don't need I don't need
be okay I just need I need to be
successful I need to make things happen
do that I'm not gonna stop you obviously
but I all I can tell you is my opinion
and I can tell you this much is that it
will never be enough
and the feeling you have will never go
away and anxiety will bring you in your
life will never make you have and then
it calls us when he wants to commit
suicide at sixty you're gonna get you're
gonna get worn out I'll tell you that's
a danger sir but I do think though that
people that get stuck in that totally
over material perspective that there is
something missing inside and you might
not see it that there might be a very
big elaborate show and shiny things and
beautiful women but I think somebody
that has immature behavior patterns like
that I think it speaks to you know an
inner vacancy I would say awesome I just
feel like I haven't reached where I want
to be financially happiness wise not
sure what I want to do all the time and
like I was there I'm sure he was there
everybody was that yeah well you don't
know what you're going I mean almost
okay I understand why I'm at where I'm
at but it's like I know he knows exactly
what yeah I know I'm sick sick I'm
saying he's on a on a mission is a
beautiful thing that level of energy
dedication focus yeah that will attain
mass loads of anything he puts his
effort to
I am because every day I'm able to get
up in the morning I'm alive
there are certain situations rapes
shootings everything out there that you
know has occurred to me to other people
I'm blessed and I'm great to be alive
because we don't know when our times
gonna be up that's 100% true that puts
it in perspective right there I mean I
think about where it came from things
that I take for granted now that I never
would have imagined at a younger age but
like you said the core blessing is to be
alive a lot of people wake up with what
am I gonna eat yeah what am I gonna go
what's this person gonna try to do to me
it's a up scuse my French state
of mind so I'm extremely grateful that
I'm on the giving side of things that I
have the ability to share and not take
necessarily I have true friends and that
I live a very very simple life and
anyone who's my life who wants to stay
in my life are very simple and very
loving at the same time I have nothing
really to complain about beside the fact
that I want to do more but even that is
like the blessing yourself because I
have the opportunity to try and do those
things to fill in coz of America but
it's the best country in the world look
at the end of your life are you a much
more loving person at the beginning your
life or even at the end of this
discussion I think I feel so I feel I've
grown a lot of learn and a privileged
speaking with everyone like we're here
the most important thing is love how
much do you love at the end of your life
come here
[Music]
thank you sup guys thank you for
checking out that middle ground episode
hope you enjoyed it one thing you guys
might not know is that the sponsor of
the middle ground series is a company
called Skillshare if you don't know
Skillshare is an online learning
platform they've got so much that you
can learn they've got like 17,000
courses something like that animation
design motion graphics film editing so
much
regardless you guys should check them
out they got a link in the description
below and the first thousand people that
use that link get two months free just
tell them I'm or I sent you